my friends let's talk about woke
especially and specifically the
perversion of the term woke to the point
where the anti-wokists don't even know
what they're talking about and what they
mean when they talk about woke before it
was perverted by the American right wing
the term woke simply meant I have become
aware of the causes of social justice
through activism pretty benign the idea
was challenge the status quo fight
against systematic and systemic
oppression to try to create a better
world
pretty benign that is not what the term
means anymore and in fact I don't even
know that anyone on the left is even
still using the term in anything other
than satirical fashion and this is
because over time the term woke has been
completely hijacked its meaning has
become vague ambiguous and has been
almost erased completely
because right Wingers have turned the
term woke into a pejorative they use it
to demonize they use it to dismiss
people advocating for social justice if
you identify an injustice the right will
dismiss your concerns by saying you are
just a wokester or go back to wokeestan
or whatever the case may be but the very
right Wingers doing that don't even
really know what the term means
understand that right-wing pundits are
masters of playing the victim of
demonizing the opposition of engaging in
binary thinking everything is either
this or that there are no gray areas in
the world and they are incredibly
effective at convincing viewers to align
with their ideology by using these dog
whistles by using these emotional
appeals and using fear and anger we've
talked about that before as well to
trigger an immediate response
the problem is many people don't even
understand what they're angry about and
that very much applies to wokeness
they're against wokeness because of CRT
and cat litter and black lives matter or
something but they've never actually
taken a moment to learn are the cat
litter stories true no they're not
is there anything about critical race
theory that is valuable or that I might
agree with in some way not that doesn't
matter they've never taken the time to
understand actually understand what are
the Grievances of the black lives matter
movement and even if I disagree with
execution for example
um or like for example me I have
concerns about the way in which
anti-Semitism has pervaded black lives
matter I can still understand
the causes and the worthiness of many of
those Caught no no no no no no they
don't even really know what it means to
be trans but they're programmed to
believe that it's it's wrong and it's
woke and these groups have all become so
powerful and they're indoctrinating
people and they're indoctrinating
children and this is how and why the
term woke
has become completely perverted it is no
longer
of course it is no longer a message to
describe or a term to describe activism
social justice but it has actually
become a tool for the right to
reflexively throw out without
understanding it to stop conversation
Remember When the Right used to love to
say to some on the left being offended
isn't an argument right you would have
these conversations where for example
during the era of uh of the gay marriage
debate such as it was you would have
this period where people on the right
would go I just believe marriage is
between a man and a woman and someone on
the left would go I find that offensive
and the person on the right would go
being offended isn't an argument and I
agreed with them being offense being
offended isn't an argument
they are now doing the exact same thing
when they go that's woke crap we don't
want woke crap they are not making an
argument they are not addressing the
merits or the facts or the substance of
any particular position or issue they
are using a term that much like I'm
offended just serves to shut down the
conversation dismiss people's concerns
and disqualify uh their participation in
those discussions so understand the term
itself has been perverted and we need to
be aware of the way in which the right
achieve that